nos encontrábamos en el sur de la
provincia de saporilla en este que es
uno de los frentes estratégicos actuales
del gobierno ucraniano Esta es una línea
no solamente para defender esta
provincia que Rusia reclama como suya
después de ese falso referéndum que hizo
meses atrás sino que es esencial para la
captura de actualmente o la recaptura
eventualmente de lo que es áreas del Sur
del país No solamente mariposa y sus
alrededores sino también la isla de
crimea que el gobierno ucraniano sigue
insistiendo que es parte de su prioridad
y que buscan conquistarla aquí nos han
contado que han habido bastantes
movimientos en los últimos meses primero
cuando retomaron la ciudad de gersón las
tropas rusas se retiraron camino más
hacia el don Baz que está al este del
país pero ahora han vuelto a regresar a
esta parte del frente especialmente como
consecuencia de esa gran movilización
que hizo el Gobierno gobierno Ruso y ha
traído muchísimos más hombres también
vuelven a reactivarse la artillería sin
embargo Aquí también aseguran que desde
que existen estos enviados por las
fuerzas aliadas de Ucrania tanto los
europeos especialmente Estados Unidos
ellos han logrado cortar días de
logística del ejército ruso lo que hace
que tengan menos acceso por lo menos a
lo que es armamento y munición lo que
hace que si bien siguen atacando con
fortaleza pues no tengan esa capacidad
que tenían meses atrás